[Music]
callbacks drag queens and Star Trek what
else could you expect from the Hocus
Pocus sequel here are some of the best
blink and you'll miss it moments and
beware spoilers ahead
the Salem of Hocus Pocus 2 is a town
just as obsessed with witchcraft and
Halloween as it was in the original film
however this time viewers are also
traded to the Salem Halloween festival
featuring the famous Sandy's candy
cauldron and an apple bobbing booth that
doubles as a drowning pool Salem in fact
is so obsessed with its Heritage that it
leans into its witch burning history a
little too hard sometimes as Becca and
Izzy head for the magic shop after
school mayor Trask stops them to wish
Becca a happy birthday as they chat a
woman dressed as a witch could be seen
behind them the odd thing about the
scene she's tied to a tree with a pyre
built under her posing for photos while
a man dressed as a Puritan holds the
camera it's a small moment barely
visible in the background and easy to
miss but subtly adds to the World
building all the same
Hocus Pocus 2 weaves Salem's history in
with the modern day creating a running
gag throughout the whole length of the
film audiences might have noticed the
film's large number of Puritan
references recalling the movie's opening
shots when Reverend Trask banishes young
Winifred in the present day the high
school mascot is appearing clearly
visible through all the scenes set in
the school as well as on Mike and his
fellow football players jerseys later
the Sanderson sisters stumble on a
look-alike contest decided by a group of
Judges dressed as Puritans
are all worshipers and this must be the
altar it's clearly an element of the
town's history that holds a lot of
meaning even if you have to give the
movie a second watch to spot all the
references
the Hocus Pocus costume department has
always been part of the film's charm
especially since building an entire town
full of Halloween fans requires a lot of
creativity the original Hocus Pocus film
used authentic costumes from other
Disney movies naturally the Hocus Pocus
2 costume Department also gave audiences
the chance to find several cheeky
callbacks to the original film
Mom
what are you supposed to be
I don't know in Hocus Pocus 2 look for
the return of Madonna stomping away in
the streets during the Musical dance
number fans might also have seen that
The Supremes are back in the original
film the trio of women wearing sparkly
red dresses can be seen in the front row
right below the stage becoming Bewitched
along with the rest of the crowd in
Hocus Pocus 2 all three are dancing
through town in the Spellbound flash mob
one of the classic scenes in the
original Hocus Pocus is when the
Sanderson sisters encounter the
flirtatious devil his disappointed wife
and their demonic yappy little dog back
in 1993 the devil was played by the
legendary Gary Marshall in an uncredited
Cameo his wife was played by his
real-life sister and actress Penny
Marshall though both stars are sadly
deceased the two lovable Oddball
characters are back in Hocus Pocus 2 for
those who watch closely while searching
for mayor Trask Winifred flies past the
window of a house where two men are
watching that scene on TV later we see
two people dressed in costume as the
devil and his wife standing behind mayor
Trask in line for caramel apples
fans of RuPaul's Drag Race should have
noticed some familiar faces on screen
during Hocus Pocus 2 and honestly who
better to face off against the three
original witches the Sanderson sisters
crash a Halloween look-alike competition
for themselves coming face to face with
ginger Minge Kimora Hall and Cornbread
as a notorious drama queen Winifred is
quick to banter with the other Winifred
lose the teeth
mind your business girl all right people
director Anne Fletcher personally
invited Ginger Minge to join the cast in
an interview with two Fab Ginger said
that watching the three witches flying
around during filming caused her to tear
up all three of them just take off
flying over our heads and that was the
moment where I just had tears streaming
down my face nine-year-old me is living
their best life
only four of the original Hocus Pocus
actors returned for the second film
Sarah Jessica Parker Kathy najimi Bette
Midler and the great Doug Jones that's
right Billy butcherson the gentle zombie
index lover is back for Hocus Pocus 2.
in the film's opening scenes Winifred is
told she'll be marrying John Pritchett
it's then that young Winifred informs
the whole town that Billy butcherson is
her soul mate especially since they
shared that kiss in the graveyard
scandalous and now Billy butcherson is
resurrected once again in service to the
Sanderson sisters however this time
Billy wants the world to know that it
was only one kiss not a fully committed
relationship a running gag that lasts
throughout the film but the real detail
is in how the actor managed to look
exactly the same almost 30 years later
not only did the costume Department
create an identical prosthetic for his
face but they used the actual wig from
the original film the wig
at someone's Creature Shop and they just
took it off and put it back on me the
original Hocus Pocus is filled with
comedica sides most of which have helped
to make the enduring film a cult classic
Hocus Pocus 2 is no different and in
fact calls back some of the jokes and
lines from the first film The most
prominent example comes about two-thirds
of the way through the film on seeing
his not so beloved Winifred again Billy
calls her a withering Hank fans of the
first film should recognize this insult
as Thackery Banks makes his last stand
in front of the sisters you hack there
are not enough children in the world to
make the Young and Beautiful
so they probably turn him into a cat as
you do however like many misunderstood
women Winifred is happy to reclaim the
insult when the sisters searched the
high school for Max Danny and Allison
the original Hocus Pocus makes it clear
that the Sanderson sisters are Servants
of Satan
Allison even tells Max and Danny that
their beloved book was given to them by
the Devil Himself however Hocus Pocus 2
did a bit of retconning with the
instruction of an evil female Mentor
dubbed mother witch who gives them the
book instead magic has a way of uniting
things they're taught to be together
but despite the switcheroo die-hard
audiences of the original Hocus Pocus
will know that the mother isn't some
random character thoughtlessly added
into the new film the Sanderson sisters
mentioned their mothers several times in
the 1993 movie Once In A calming Circle
reminiscing about mother scorpion pie
and later when they salute their
long-lost mother with their brooms
only the most eagle-eyed viewers would
have caught the name of the high school
displayed in the background behind Becca
in this scene Becca and dizzy discuss
their Halloween plans and right behind
them is Samuel Skelton High School
written right over the archway while
it's tempting to connect the school's
name to the Lovecraft song skeleton Sam
that plays at the beginning of the film
Samuel Skelton is actually a real person
from Salem's history skeleton was the
first pastor of the first church in
Salem founded on August 6th 1629.
in modern day Salem the Sanderson
sisters spooky old house has been turned
into a delightful magic shop naturally
this being a Disney film viewers should
pay close attention to the decoration
shown in the background for instance
fans of Disney's classic Haunted Mansion
ride should recognize the skull of the
hatbox ghost standing out from a group
of skulls in one corner that's not all
though sharp-eyed viewers might have
seen the words Salem's Apothecary
written on the corner above the counter
a clever Easter egg since the Sanderson
sisters talk about their father's
Apothecary several times during the film
finally in one scene you can spot a
basket of plush yarn-haired Sanderson
sister dolls on a table
no one would argue that book had an
important role in the first Hocus Pocus
the spell book which was apparently
bound in human skin became an iconic
part of the Hocus Pocus mythology and
aesthetic however it's in Hocus Pocus 2
that book finally gets a chance to shine
showing off its personality
demonstrating its opinions and even
making choices about who's going to be
its next witch fans may have noticed
that when book is hiding from Becca
amongst the other non-sention spellbooks
it physically sweats because get it it's
bound in human skin as a side note
there's also a reference to Star Trek
when book refuses to open onto the
correct page for the magikai Maxima
spell in a rage Winifred shows a famous
Star Trek line
foreign
[Music]
did that line make it in because Doug
Jones the actor and contortionist who
plays Billy butcherson stars as saru and
Star Trek Discovery or was it just a fun
thing to shout out at a book that
suddenly decided to have a mind of its
own
moviegoers should know this one already
stay until after the credits Hocus Pocus
2 is no different from any other
superhero film Muppet movie or animated
film in modern history there's always
something to see after the credits roll
the original Hocus Pocus shows Max and
Danny's parents Jenny and Dave emerging
from the town hall a little worse for
wear after their night dancing in Hocus
Pocus 2 fans are treated to the
possibility of yet another film cobweb
Gilbert's black cat jumps onto a shelf
in the Back store room nosing among the
boxes naturally audiences can see that
one of the boxes is labeled BF number
two candle could it be that audiences
are getting a third Hocus Pocus let's
hope so
[Music]